I try to make safer drugs every day and
that I look for the twetos to using
animals and so I have models that live
in little tissue culture flasks and
little organelles that swim around you
know reagent flasks and then I try to
model what's reality and try to make
safer drugs for patients it's actually
interesting because traditionally safety
is thought to be you know occurring
pretty late in the process and drug
development so you spend years of
defining your target developing
molecules looking at efficacy and then
at some point you ask the question oh is
it safe to now go into a patient and try
it out in a trial and so you have to go
through a rigorous you know safety
testing in the animal and so that's what
has traditionally been done and on many
occasions we thought it was safe in the
animal and then later on in the patient
we saw that you know it had liabilities
anyway so the thought that we have was
in Pfizer at least you know a lot of us
by now as to really start this much much
earlier so the minute somebody says I
think this is a good target we start
thinking about it you know what do we
know from competitors what do we know
from the literature can we you know
identify possible risks for that target
or for that chemical series that might
target it and then we start thinking
about it and and also designing some
experiments around it
you